[Music]
been waiting for
Reeta or not only part of the Fifty
Shades family she also sings on the
soundtrack for Fifty Shades breed out
today a lot of people looking forward to
this one I sat down with Reed in Paris
where she revealed that she had some
nerves when it came to her duet with a
One Direction
[Music]
Liam Payne is so lovely to work with
very professional
I didn't know how I was gonna go down
because those one Directioners are like
crazy massive you didn't come in with
like a full entourage but you know I
know that's why I am a num'rous I mean
that was so massive yeah so I thought
yeah I'm probably gonna have to look on
the floor he was no eye contact but he
was super nice
to do a solo on the soundtrack it was
like my initial goal before everybody's
involved in the movie
Rita plays Dakota Johnson sister-in-law
kidnapped my stalker Jack Hyde played by
Eric Johnson hell are ya Anna no food no
food no water
we're used to seeing people tied up in
this film but not quite like that Eric's
wife actually helped him prepare his
wife loves the books what did she think
of you being a little bit evil oh she
looks knew she knew right away she knew
she's like Ali indeed after wrapping the
film Rita had many Brits childhood dream
come true sure Kensington Palace
experience with your secret crush please
hurry
it's a secret as a kid it's like
everyone wanted to hang out with Harry
because he was the fun one
how'd you handle yourself we did we'd
like to keep it cool no of course I did
you know of course I kept her respectful
and I'm respectful of his wedding which
I think is gonna be so good and bars
like that I love I'm crazy you know I do
love the royal family
reaction to Megan merkel joining the
family band is not the best it's great
welcome
[Music]